actually I went to church when I when I
was younger and my dad's made me go and
I went and I had a good time and then as
I got older I kind of dropped it out and
I went for a time in my life in 2013 and
um I thought like a lot of people speak
to God when they're all sleep in the
ship or when they when they need a bit
of guidance or need a bit of help not
like oh God you know I'm doing good and
XYZ I feel like back then I looked so
good to help me in a situation and God's
told me that the outcome that I wanted
to happen ain't gonna happen and guess
what it never happened good was right
and from then I said you know what there
is someone up there I'm not crazy